hey everyone this is steve weintraub
with collider and i am thrilled to be
with the people behind all quiet on the
western front here at our toronto
international film festival studio uh
gentlemen as i said to you off camera
and i'll say it on camera i thought your
film is fantastic and a very powerful
look at uh the german side of world war
one um i definitely have so many
questions um but for people that have
actually it's a little generic and i
apologize but for people that have not
actually read the book have not seen the
previous films um how have you been
describing the film to like friends and
family or to people that don't know the
material
um it's a story about a young man paul
who gets
influenced by
the the propaganda of the time and he
and his friends
go enthusiastically into world war one
to fight it and they think it's going to
be over very soon only to discover that
the trenches and the mud and the blood
and the terror
destroys basically their soul
what listen making any movie is a
challenge and requires a tremendous
amount of your time what was it about
this material that said i want to adapt
this i want to make a new version of
this material
so this this it's a very very famous
german novel that's been with us since
i'm you know since i'm a young kid
and it's a very famous you know and and
and we we we have a very different
attitude towards war or we have a very
different education with war we have
very different cultural heritage germany
obviously started two wars in the last
century and brought a lot of terror and
horror to the world
and we felt that that perspective
is an important one to tell because
obviously a movie from if if you're born
with that
the movie will feel very different
from an american movie or british movie
that where soldiers went to war wanted
were celebrated victoriously
and uh brought home a different kind of
feeling and we didn't grow up with that
feeling so we wanted to share that that
that emotion with with an international
audience so uh i would imagine um man i
have so many questions for you and i
have questions for you give me just one
second but one of the things that struck
me was the the beautiful imagery at the
beginning of the film of the forest and
the animals before it really
what was your
motivation for having that sort of
photography at the beginning of the film
well we cut a lot to
also throughout the film to nature the
film ends with nature
um um and the foxes was an imagery of
warmth
of motherhood or family of feeling
you know togetherness
giving us possibly a sense of what we
might lose you know in the in the in the
in the wake of destruction
i would imagine this was for you
um a dream role
a great project to get um and uh
and also a real challenge uh because it
was
when you watch the film you'll people
will understand what what was the what
what did you take away from this project
as an actor um that you'll take with you
for like the rest of your life
um i train goosebumps i trained my the
rhythm of my heart
for example when it says an action and
500 people started working i never had
that experience before
so the camera would start somewhere on
the battlefield and then dive into the
trenches and end up um
on felix and me and that was kind of
a new thing for me definitely
because you could mess it up and then
500 people have to restart and a restart
is not like that it takes what half an
hour at least yeah yeah
so that was something i definitely gonna
take um take with off this project and
to meet this wonderful felix who
unfortunately can't be here felix camera
the main actor
one one of the things i can't imagine as
an actor when you're in scenes like that
with that many people how much is it
every night before you're going to sleep
you thinking about the scenes of the
next day and sort of going through the
motions
of what you're going to be doing and is
it easy to sleep when you are
responsible for these kinds of moments
i think um we adapted a different sleep
um
we we we dived into that project um for
months
so
your
well at least my
whole system kind of changed i had
different dreams
because i ate differently i made
different sports
i quit smoking during the project
after i was smoking for 24 years so it
was everything for
kind of the story and we we would have a
little chat before we went to sleep with
with the others
and um and that's it and then on the
next day we would have um would have
been again on the trenches so
yeah we kind of really dived into this
i'm so curious obviously there's been
many films made i think of saving
private ryan i think i mean full metal
jacket you name it i've seen we've all
seen so many as a director how much are
you looking at other
war movies before filming to see what
you like what you don't like and how
much are you sort of like i don't want
to look at any of these because i don't
want to be influenced at all on what i'm
about to do
i i want to watch all of them and all
the time that's what i do you know like
during a process like that i've seen
them all i've watched them many times
and and they just um seep into you into
your perception into your into your body
in a way and the main thing really is
what i said earlier is what what feels
like
our how we are educated how we are
brought up and or how american or
british filmmaker or anywhere else in
the world is brought up that influences
the film most so
so you know what you bring to it from
from your birth you know from your
education that goes into the film in
every decision you know are the are the
actors heroes are the are we glorifying
anything is the music kind of
celebrating a moment is the camera too
clean so all of that influences the
language of the film and we can't even
help it you know i can't make a film
that would celebrate a soldier in any
way you know because because of our
history and so that that influences it
the most more than any movie so i'm not
afraid to watch other movies other
warmers i actually cherish them and love
them and see how they did it and to
understand how their education how their
life how those filmmakers lives
influence their films and they're all of
all of them are different one of the
things that i found watching the project
is that we're watching the film is that
there's no everything felt very
authentic to me and very much not
hollywoodized if i can use that term i
felt like the camera was just there and
these events were happening can you sort
of talk about that aspect of trying to
make it where you know you're almost a
fly on the wall and you're delivering as
authentic of a performance as you can
deliver well we try to put we try to
understand in every decision where we
put the camera it was always like we
looked at cut his character
and said what is he feeling right now
what do we want the audience to feel and
that always
uh informed the decision of where to put
the camera should it be here you know to
feel slightly oppressive or here or just
watching him and just calmly staying
back a little bit and let him do the
work and we just document it in a way so
the camera was following
what his performance was what paul
boymer's felix camera the actor's
performance was
and just just trying to capture what
they were feeling so that the audience
could identify with their emotions and
that's
uh but with never really
pressing too many buttons you know not
i don't want to try i want to try the
camera always manipulates but i want to
try to manipulate as little as possible
or to to not give the audience the
feeling that they are manipulated
actually that was the content of one of
maybe it was the content of our first
meeting actually because it was one of
my biggest fear that um it could glorify
something
since yeah and um
i was very happy when i heard that he's
going to do a movie like that that he is
interested in the stories of the people
and not to do like an
adventurous
war movie
uh what people might not realize about
all quiet on the western front is and i
believe it was one of the first books to
be banned um and it was definitely
banned by nazi germany
and i think about what's going on today
and
and i'm not sure if you're aware in
america but some of these states burning
books that are not i mean it's crazy um
uh can you sort of talk about the fact
that like you you know this your story
takes place over a hundred years ago but
really nothing has changed
that was a big motivation for us to make
the film uh we felt when we started the
film there was no war in the ukraine yet
so it's not a comment on on the war on
the ukraine but obviously the subject
matter we don't seem to learn you know
the subject matter seems to repeat
itself you mentioned these events in the
states it's happening all over the world
certainly happens in russia as well
and when we started it it felt like the
language all over the world is getting
harsher
you had politicians in america who were
screaming loudly about separating
putting people apart you had politicians
in the uk definitely there was brexit
there was
uh
people far right parties being voted
into power in several countries in the
european union hungary southern france
was in danger or france was in danger of
becoming far right and italy now has is
in danger of voting far right so there
is there's a rising party in germany
which is far right so that it's all
happening all over this like and that
also made us think it's the you know
demagogues
are questioning 70 years of peace time
the longest peace time in history
uh when we started the film and so it
seemed to be a very timely you know
topic to make and and it's it it seems
to
seems still to be relevant today
um i'm always fascinated by the editing
process because it's ultimately where it
all comes together so can you talk a
little bit about what you learned when
you started cutting the film from
friends and family that impacted the
finished film i mean editing for me is
such a horror because it takes you start
the film and
to edit and for the first few weeks you
think this is the worst thing ever made
yeah because everything is
is not together yet it has no rhythm it
has doesn't have the right colors it
doesn't have the right music you're
trying to find the language
so and we had a lot of uh material also
yeah and then to put an order into that
and to carve out the movie is a real
process and you have to and never
somehow it's always a miracle to me how
it then eventually comes together and we
had
friends and family screenings quite late
because i wanted to find it first for a
long time and then but once we had it
you realize
hmm okay they'll understand much quicker
than you thought they uh i was afraid
for the first cut of the movie for
example was
i don't know
two hours and five minutes
short shorter shorter than it is now
because i was afraid when i saw the
first cut it was almost three hours you
know and i thought this is so boring
this is so long let's cut cut cut cut so
i cut it down to two hours in five
minutes i showed it and i realized it's
too fast it's rushing by it doesn't have
a rhythm and actually we got that
feedback from netflix even i showed it
to my executive at netflix sasha bula
and she said it just feels a bit rushed
and i was really surprised usually you
know people say two hours and five
minutes you know it shouldn't be longer
you know it's already a healthy length
without credits so
and then we found the film's length
eventually at two hours and 20 plus
credits
and that felt that felt to be that it
needed that air it needed that breadth
and and and uh everyone including
you know our wonderful friends at
netflix said it you know this is what
this film needs and and
and that's how you know it was it's it's
also a rhythm and a length question and
and the audience uh very much helps you
find that yeah i i thought the the cut
that i watched um ultimately uh is
fantastic the version that you
eventually ended up with have you seen
the finished film
yes and what was it like what is it like
for for you
an actor um who i'm sure gave your heart
and soul to this project watching it for
the first time in a darkened theater
what's going through your mind and can
you separate yourself from your perform
like you know what i mean yeah yeah sure
sure um it's it's getting better i'd say
but um
for sure i mean i'm i'm
i'm in the subjective position
um
most of myself watching
me playing cut
and then
examine
what went right what went wrong what
could have been better all those
questions right
um but i was able to see the movie at
least
for fifty percent as a movie you know
what i mean apart from my performance so
i can't wait to watch it today again for
the second time here on tiff
sure with an audience you're also gonna
it's gonna be exactly because that is
when a movie becomes you know a movie
when when it meets the audience 100 um
for both of you when you are uh shooting
a film you're looking at the schedule
you know there must be a day or two
circled that you know are going to be
really effing hard days or really
emotional days where you're going to
have to dig deep or the technical
challenges with the camera whatever
you're trying to pull off it's going to
be next to impossible so for each of you
what was that day or days during the
shoot that really had you
like you know
thinking about
do you want to start
uh i think it was the scene which is not
in the movie well at least cut out
three-third of the scene i guess
and it turned out to be
yes a tough one but we had a wonderful
team who really took care of us it was
very rainy the whole day for i don't
know how long for two days i don't know
and uh then we just had in the movie one
third of the scene but another scene
turned out to be the most challenging
which i thought it's going to be the
most i don't i don't know fun scene to
be it's uh the scene when they eat the
eggs
you know they they are coming running
away from the barn and having the eggs
um
and we ate them for about i don't know
30 times maybe 20 times 20 to 30 times
and of course
it was it was something uh made up
extract of sugar and
something
and uh
let's let's keep it like that um we had
a synchronized
reaction of our bodies
felix and me
we had to break and from that day on
they decided not to have no toilets on
set anymore
sorry
no but i wasn't too surprised specific
on that right but no but what's funny is
i've been on a lot of movie sets and tv
sets and when you're filming on location
i'm always looking around do are people
aware that they need to eat carefully
because there's no bathroom in any
vicinity of where i'm standing
like but i'm being this is like a
practical real thing absolutely it's
always problematic so we had a i think
we had a 54-day schedule or something
like that wait time out you shot this in
54 days yeah it was yeah i think maybe
even 53 i've got something like that and
it's a very ambitious
film for a 53-day shoot that's what i
wanted to say so when you asked which
day was circled as a panic day it was
probably 52 days that was circuit i
think we're never ever gonna make that
no the most the biggest challenge
was really uh
we have
very big battle scenes
that i have never done before that's
also a reason why you make a movie like
this you know it's not only the story
that you want to tell but the challenge
the hurdle that you want to jump over
you know this i haven't done it so let's
try to get it and very often i always
wrote to set with a cinematographer in
the morning and we looked at each other
and i almost cried because i thought
we're never ever going to make this day
uh with uh going to set you know with
the with the battle scenes especially
tanks
flamethrowers
these guys having 100 yield weapons in
their hands that constantly jammed yeah
so
him speaking about the panic of
ruining a take it's not even you know
him but it's the gun that jams you know
and that screws up everything and then
you re you're like oh god we're going to
have to reset everything it's going to
take 45 minutes to get everyone to the
beginning so there were constantly
challenges like that where you think
like we're never ever going to make this
one of the things about uh i've spoken
to many directors um and one of the
things that happens is that you know
you're you're constantly trying to get
to that next level in terms of what you
can accomplish on screen you mentioned
you've never done battle scenes you've
never worked with tanks or whatever it
may be um are you looking forward as a
director to taking what you learned on
this project and trying to do something
even bigger for your next thing or do
you feel like i need i almost want to
take a step back and go a little smaller
for my next project
no i actually want to do so the film is
uh
you know you set you set in it and at
the end i wanted the audience to feel
something and take it home for five you
know sit in your seat think about it for
two minutes take that feeling that we
try to convey of these young men of
these soldiers and take it with you for
five minutes for an hour maybe overnight
think about it feel the movie
and
feel the ramifications of the movie
and and the movie is very silent in the
end there's no song
so my biggest goal and my biggest
ambition is
to the next movie
uh cut to the credits put a great pop
song on it
have people go have the lights go up and
people go like that was great that was
really fun should we go to dinner and
just forget about it you know just just
fun and entertainment that's what i
would like to do next but also
i like to you know uh jump over a bigger
hurdle i like i like these challenges
and i want i would like to
you know
get a new challenge and and and
uh it's not really the size of the
project that doesn't matter it could be
a smaller movie it could be a bigger
movie but something that i haven't done
sure what some one some of the really
powerful stuff to me in the movie is and
i don't want to be specific with anyone
with things and that's the reason of
being more vague because most people
will not have seen it yet um is there's
a lot of moments of the leaders and the
way their lives are leading and what
they're eating and the the environment
they're standing in versus what the
soldiers are doing after being you know
um
you know with blind nationalism you know
and what they've sort of led down that
path uh and you present it without
comment it's sort of just matter of fact
like this is what you know letting the
audience come to that realization can
you sort of talk about that aspect
well it's automatically if you put the
contrast in like what the soldiers are
eating that they're hungry for example
they didn't have any food in the german
lines and whenever they it's it's
researched whenever they went to the
french lines and there's a big scene
about them uh just gobbling down french
food because they had sausages they had
cheese they had good bread and they
would just go into their canteen and go
like
they just shovel everything down because
they're hungry they're hungry you need
food they're cold they're hungry they're
freezing and the contrast of
then the higher-ups the generals the the
diplomats of course they were taken care
of and you don't need to comment on that
because automatically the contrast the
audience puts it together oh that looks
quite luxurious the way they live
and that's already interesting without
commenting
um when you think back on this
project for you
what is going to be the thing that you
will always remember uh in terms of
you know just making this film and uh
the way it possibly has changed your
life or the way you look at the world
i think
it will be
obvious when we had the premiere
because this is this is a chapter to be
told
it's not done yet
the movie is done when we had the
premiere and we
got the reactions of the audience
and then i
probably or might be able to answer your
question
your film is going to be the german
submission for oscars this year um when
did you find out that it was going to be
the submission and what does it mean to
both of you
we found out about two weeks ago there's
a there's a jury who selects it and it
means a whole lot because it means that
the world that more people in the world
can see it that there's more that there
will be more screenings that there will
be a bigger audience that there will be
a bigger marketing push for it that it's
just more accessible to people and that
people pay more attention to it so
that's the main thing that you
that you can carry this film
share what the story that we wanted to
tell and share with more people
it's wonderful
um so uh i'm running out of time with
you guys but i what we do uh when with a
lot of people that come in is we do
something called get to know your tiff
attendee uh and it's some fun questions
and i promise these are harmless um but
if you could guest write and direct a tv
show what would it be and what tv show
would you love to guest star on
all right succession
fleabag
um what movie do you think you've seen
the most
apocalypse now
oh once upon a time in america
you guys know this stuff down um what tv
show have you seen all the way through
more than once
what tv show yeah or if you have have
you seen any tv shows all the way
through more than more than once
i never saw a tv show all the way
through once uh twice
so but the one i saw once all the way
through that always stays with me is the
sopranos six feet under
i watched um two times mark ruffalo
playing
him well his brother and himself or oh
the derek the terrex cinefrance series
all i all like well i have no uh um all
i know is no um all i know is true no i
think that might be it i know it's true
yeah it's it's the derek it's a six
episode director i know this much it's
true yes it's a it's a fantastic series
yeah derek is a very very very
yeah very very talented director um
if you could get the financing to make
anything you want what would you make
and why
i mean that was it or was this
so i have to come up with a new one you
know it was like really all quiet uh
when it came up i thought wow that's a
dream project that's basically our
apocalypse now we can tell our
apocalypse now so that's what i said to
the producer at some point i would say
the next one i mean the one i want to do
is a big action adventure movie that i
would love i would love to a fun big
action adventure movie that's or no
it's actually
it's actually i really would love to do
james bond
i mean
that's my dream
uh you know something i've i'm i'm a big
fan or i really do believe in putting it
out there uh if you want something um
just because otherwise no one will ever
know sure i tell everybody i just had
forgotten for a second i tell everybody
my big goal is to make a james bond yes
i say yes
obviously starring or a co-star role
yeah absolutely uh in case i have time
because not working with paul thomas
anderson at the moment right
i understand is there anything that you
collect
or obsess over
books
are you one of these people that
collects first editions
no it doesn't matter i don't care i
don't have one single first edition can
be a paperback can be used one it
doesn't matter
stones really yeah do you like pick them
up where you're filming things um i i
just the other day i picked up a stone
from the lake here in toronto
so it's kind of uh to get connected to
the place i am it's it could be it's
it's not a very i don't know
yeah it could be a random stone that
just you know that i like to pick up not
because it looks very precious you say
that yeah
and do you take them home yeah i i did
that and i give them away as a present
oh that's interesting i've i collected
some stones on some um some rocks on
some set visits i did like lord of the
rings and other things and i've saved
them
but i keep them because i'm selfish
i'm going to say it like that um
uh
i guess i think i'm i'm trying to oh my
last question for you what do you wish
more people knew about making movies
the the the the the what people see is
the glamour the red carpet the premiere
the press and so forth it's i can tell
you it's not glamorous
albrecht told the story of eating eggs
and not finding the proper spot to
then deal with the ramifications that's
what it is albrecht told the story of uh
of having to work in the rain and then
you really work in the rain for 12 hours
and it's cold and it's wet and it's not
comfortable and these guys were amazing
because they kept singing you know
despite the the challenges
but it's cold it's muddy it's freezing
it's not coming it's not fun you know
it's really hard work and it's
definitely not glamorous especially with
this film when i was watching it and i
saw the mud and everything you went
through i'm like oh this was not an easy
shoot this was a backbreaker
totally for everyone for the crew i mean
i sometimes had crew coming up to me on
the battlefield at night and said do you
know do you know how much i walked this
day a half marathon
in winter clothes
yeah well i'm going to say to you and i
mean this sincerely it your dedication
to your craft
really shows in this movie it is a
fantastic film that i really commend you
guys on um and uh there's a reason it's
at the toronto film festival the german
submission for the oscar
i wish you guys nothing but the best and
thank you so much for coming in our
studio thank you so very much that's
very kind thank you
you